Writing your code into R
scripts is valuable for
managing and organizing
R objects.
But sometimes you may
wish to clear some
objects from your workspace.
To get a look at what objects
exist in your current
workspace, use the
ls function.
If you want to remove an
object, use the remove
function with the argument
name as the
object to be removed.
If you want to remove all the
objects in a workspace, you
can use the list argument in
the remove function and
specify all of the objects
in the workspace
using the ls function.
It's also helpful to be able
to easily convert between
objects of different types.
We'll consider three functions
for converting objects to
numerical, character, and
factor object types.
For instance, we can apply
each of these functions
to the object x.
Applying the as.character and
the as.factor functions affect
the outcome.
Had I wanted to actually change
x to, say, a factor, I
could have assigned the
new result to x.
One special note here--
if you have a factor variable
that also looks numeric,
always convert it to a character
before converting it
to numerical value.
There are other comparable
functions that you may
occasionally find useful, such
as as.matrix, as.data.frame,
and as.list.
One last function I'll consider
in this video is the
on list function.
In the usual process of data
analysis, I might create a
list to hold summary and results
of an experiment.
Here, I'll construct a list
manually for four groups.
In this example, you can think
of the first number for a
group to represent its
corresponding sample size.
The second number might
represent the average response
for that group.
And the third value might
represent the standard
deviation for the group.
Just a side note worth
mentioning.
I typically perform these types
of calculations in an
automated way, which would make
it easier for the code to
be scaled to an arbitrary
number of groups.
If you need a refresher on this
topic, look back to the
fifth video in Section 2.
All right, so the results are
stored in the list, where each
list item represents the results
for a single group.
If I unlist this subject,
I get a vector of
the unlisted results.
It would actually be more useful
to hold this object as
a matrix or as a data frame,
so I'll form these unlisted
results into a matrix.
If I'd prefer a data frame, I
could use the as.data.frame
function applied
to this matrix.
If I wanted, I could also just
the call names of the data
frame using the names or the
column names function.
In the next video, we'll explore
the family of apply
functions, which are helpful for
applying a function across
the rows or columns of a
matrix or across the
elements of a list.